le 21 novembre dernier la mère michel
est clair bouleversé la france
souvenez-vous de ce producteur de
musique passé à tabac par des policiers
à paris des images de cette
interpellation et ce déchaînement de
violence inouïe avait été révélée par
l'outsider et avait fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce qui se passe du mode ta bosse
face à ces images les médias avaient
décidé de propulser cette affaire en une
de l'actualité
à l'époque michel était venu nous
raconter son calvaire dans l'émission
jamais vécu quelque chose comme ça je me
frustre and co les deux policiers
responsables de cette bavure avait été
placé en détention provisoire avant
d'être relâchés le 22 décembre dernier
tout en restant sous contrôle judiciaire
strict trois mois après les traits
michel revient sur notre plateau pour
nous parler de sa lente reconstruction
et de son avenir
on est très heureux d'avoir sur le
plateau michel producteur de musique
merci d'être là michel merci beaucoup
avant avant qu'on demande vraiment où tu
en es etc
il ya quand même des bonnes nouvelles
parce que tu je vous le dit michel il a
travaillé avec la fouine avec booba avec
rohff donc avec des très très très
grands noms et aujourd'hui tu repères et
tu produis de jeunes artistes qui sont
en train d'exploser
delpierre scellé il y aura d'ailleurs
ciena c'est une de tes artistes qui sera
avec moi jamais vendredi qui fera qui
nous fera un titre et si vous voulez
faire vous devrez montrer ce que tu as
fait vendredi dernier sur le single est
sorti vendredi dernier elle sera chez
benjamin vendredi son single s'appelle
en bombe et un autre artiste par un
jeune rappeur qui sort son premier
projet vendredi avec notamment le clip
j'ai le sommet ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il
était en train d'enregistrer ce titre au
studio moment ton agression c'est mal tu
y es b et vous avez même mis des images
donc des vidéosurveillances non le clip
alors on va on va voir on a fait une
petite compil des deux artistes regardez
c'est dans ma kou perte par action se
prennent par l'état science personnes
quand tu as été ma chronique de
satisfaire ses plans insisté on connaît
le système doit être assistée fait c'est
un système en a coupé je te parle de
système
[Musique]
pour toi
une méga
en bas
qu'appelle-t-on pions
bien quoi
encore
t'as plus tôt
les miens mais qu'ils veulent très fort
c'est cette fort et c'est une halle sera
avec benjamin castaldi mondiale arrivant
ici et le tchador ce sens bien je te le
dis le son est très fort voilà j'attends
de voir ton thing du coup je te le dis
je vais le faire je vais le faire et je
rigole pas
je le ferai demain avec plaisir bonbons
michel donc ça ça va tu as pu contre
recommencer à travailler voilà tu es tu
es sur tes trucs et c'est vrai que là
deux artistes je pense qu'ils avancent
iéna je kiffe et l'autre que l'auto
cissé c'est fort et donc tamis des
images de de ton agression dans le trip
comment vois tu t'es toi t'as fait ça
c'est l'artiste qui t'a demandé non
c'est la rédactrice
qui est aussi mon associé d'accord et
et les radiateurs à dr dans un délire
c'est ce titre qu'on a fait on voit le
mois le clip est là bas et puis et puis
ça coulait de source
alors trois mois après les faits déjà
comment tu vas me michel mas disons que
mon état fluctue un truc qu au bras
comment ça s'est passé une attelle bas
comme j'ai eu le tendon sectionné on l'a
ressouder avec une encre où on a
ressoudé monfils est du coup et après
j'ai forcément une rééducation à faire
trois mois après tu as encore un voyage
et je crois que dans pas longtemps je
pourrais je pourrais m'en séparer
complètement et est dans la tête
comment ça va c'est moi et au corps suis
remis plus vite que la tête je crois
dans la tête tu es comment c'est
toujours compliqué mais on fait en sorte
comme s'il avait pu encaisser quoi que
tu te reste traumatisée tu as tes voilà
qu'ils repensent tu arrives à dormir
normalement tu arrives à mais c'est
vraiment un match que j'ai un peu de mal
mais je crois qu est ce qui ce qui est
bien dans la nuit qui se tapent tel
talent angoisse t ce jeu c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je me fais suivre là
dessus mais tu t'es fait su après
l'agression que tu as décidé de te faire
suivre pour pour essayer de douala de
tête surmontée dès que j'ai compris que
tout seul ça risque d'être compliqué je
préfère je pense que j'en ai besoin
et puis qu'est-ce que tu te fais suivre
puis qu'est-ce que tu essaies de
vraiment de d'essayer de passer à autre
chose et c'est quoi essayez d'enlever
toutes ces mauvaises images qui a dans
ta tête tout et c'est plutôt de ne plus
être traumatisé peut-être quand tu vois
un policier parce que je sais que
c'était c'était ce qui est traumatisé
dès que tu voyais un uniforme
c'était un petit peu on stresse
c'est que c'est pas évident du coup
j'essaie de me battre contre ça tout ça
c'est vraiment difficile
jeux jeux ça me fait beaucoup de bien
d'ailleurs de pouvoir évacuer tout ça
donc dans ta écédent d'évacuer tout ça
de way alors est ce que ta part donné
aux policiers
je pense que lors du pardon c'est je
pense pas que ce soit maintenant
aujourd'hui moi je ce que je voudrais
c'est c'est que l'anc est ce fini ce
qu'on puisse la requête est en cours
est ce que quand tu croises des
policiers dans la rue est ce que est ce
qu'il y en a peut-être connu quittons
nous parler ou est-ce que temps ça s'est
passé ce que c'est on a envie de savoir
aussi ce qu'est des policiers qui sont
du devoir qui ont dit oui on comprend
que tu sois traumatisée est ce que c'est
important de le dire aux téléspectateurs
aussi pour qu'ils comprennent que tous
les politiques voilà sont pas des
dépouilles c'est ça qu'il faut le dire
oui michel sait pas du tout ce qu'ils
pensent parce que est-ce que tu avec des
témoignages de policiers qui m'ont dit
on est avec toi et voilà on cautionne
pas ce qui s'est passé
oui je sens la difficulté pour eux de
pouvoir s'exprimer normalement mais oui
j'ai pas mal de policiers de gendarmes
aussi qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord du
tout avec les agissements de ce qu'ils
quittent on dit vous remercier souvent
c'est vrai ouais ils disent comment ils
tournaient leur mur qui traverse d'abord
parce que c'est ce que je dis souvent
quand j'ai des policiers des gendarmes
sur le plateau je le redis ce genre
d'agissements ça leur fait énormément de
mal et c'est vrai que derrière eux ils
ont beaucoup plus de mal à faire leur
travail derrière donc c'est pour ça
qu'il te remercie pour avoir mis cette
lui mais cette affaire en lumière et
pour avoir dénoncé ce qui s'était passé
ouais enfin taux plus je pense que c'est
plus
pour avoir fait la part des choses
d'accord c'est ça aussi c'est ce que tu
avais dit sur ce plateau quand on est
venu tu avais dit voilà moi j'en veux à
ses policiers là mais je n'en veux pas à
la police et avaient appelé tous les
voilà tous les gens qui nous regardent
anpaa voilà s'en prendre à la police et
que tu avais dit que la majorité des
policiers étaient des gens bien et que
toi tu étais peut-être tombé sur et des
dégâts qui faisait mal leur boulot
je pense que c'est nécessaire de le dire
et on est mon 10 avec le déclenchement
se reconnaissent dans la rue et des
policiers se disent ouais quand même
même avec le masque et thoune jeu ouais
temps j'essaie de me camoufle et c'est
moi je suis pas sûr je sais toi t'as pas
envie d'être sur le devant de la scène
des collations santé derrière tu as
toujours été derrière des producteurs tu
as envie de mettre justement des jeunes
talents voilà sur le devant de la scène
et en lumière et ils te disent quoi
la première chose qu'ils disent est ce
que c'est vous c'est moi et puis et puis
après sang tan des fois une petite
discussion où la peur quand il
s'approche de toi maintenant est ce que
tu as déjà vu tu t'es ya là il ya quand
même un truc eddine l ascension d un
truc qui se passe quand même l'essai et
c'est vraiment à l'intérieur de ton
corps tu te sens une petite dépression
un petit truc qui n'est pas normal
finalement assez sec quand tu rentres
dans des studios à chaque fois tenu
petite appréhension je jeu s'est dressée
au aux alentours pourtant même les
policiers qui sont aux alentours ont
jamais eu de problème avec eux mais bon
je préfère quand même assez sombre dans
des zones où il ya des caméras
quand tu as entendu des gens aussi qui
sont dit ce que j'ai lu - notamment des
éditorialistes ont dit bah si ça c'est
pas que c'est comme ça c'est qu'il avait
dû faire quelque chose ou un tatoo
journée les voiles à des personnes mal
intentionnées qui disent oui bah c'est
pas possible que qui rien eu avant
qu'ils se soient fait agresser comme ça
sans que rien ne se passe et comment tu
réagis est ce que ça te fait mal
oui ça me touche maintenant
c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas à ça
parce que dès le début je il ya une
caméra dans la rue bien sûr caméras
publiques dans la rue donc moi pour moi
j'étais couvert par rapport à cette
caméra là donc on verra ce que ça va
donner
et une caméra l'a vu dans la rue donc
pour savoir ce que ce que je faisais
avant
on pourra très facilement le me voir et
en même temps aussi le nombre de
messages de célébrités comme antoine
griezmann ou d'anonymes voilà elle se
sou voilà il ya eu plein de gens qui
disent qu'ils sont voilà qu'il ya une
vague d'indignation dans toute la france
pour te soutenir
est ce que ça t'a fait du bien ça me
touche beaucoup il ya des gens qui te
reconnaît aussi dans leur reer par des
policiers ou pas oui ça arrive et puis
ils sont très bienveillant et puis
souvent jeu
d'ailleurs j'ai du mal avec ça parce que
je les sens très touché je les sens
toucher
sincèrement dernièrement la gg j'ai une
fenêtre d'une mère qui m'a vraiment
beaucoup touché ou a expliqué que son
fils était et est incarcéré pour outrage
et qu' il crie son innocence et que et
qu'après mon moi mon et si oui voilà
elle commence à croire son fils donc
c'est vrai que c'est il ya des choses
qui sont quand même assez difficile
je veux pas me mettre à leur place mais
c'est je sais que c'est pas évident nous
savons en l enquête aujourd'hui parce
que vous avez 100% cours on n'attend pas
mal de choses
et montre aussi pour avoir lieu pendant
de nombreux mois
j'aimerais plus vite possible au final
des mariés peuvent aussi ce que vous
pensez que le procès et que les affaires
soient jugées ça va vous permettre aussi
de passer à autre chose d'essayer de
voilà vous pensé beaucoup à ça au procès
à la caisse que j'ai pas le choix de
toute façon vu que même si j'essaye
d'oublier
je vois le juge d'instruction il faut je
regarde des images que j'explique image
par image
ça vous remet dedans à chaque fois tout
le temps ce que vous avez un esprit de
vengeance ou bien vous dit non je suis
pas là dedans j'ai juste envie de me
reconstruire mois non non j'ai envie que
justice se fasse en fait j'ai envie que
vous avez besoin pour passer à autre
chose
bien sûr assez ça revient cher même dans
dans ma tête ce qui est ce qui s'est
produit
j'ai besoin qu'on puisse me dire
juridiquement tu n'étais pas en tort ils
ont eu tort et ils vont payer pour ça
enfin je j'ai envie que que que lui il
faut que je passe à autre chose
essentielle est important pour vous
reconstruire c'est ça bien sûr c'est
quoi le plus dur pour se reconstruire
c'est quoi aujourd'hui au jour le jour
est ce que votre famille vous avez je
crois que c'est une fille j'ai un frère
à frère d'accord avec et vous avez des
enfants n'ont pas de trac or et votre
frère votre mm je sais que votre voix
votre associé que j'aime beaucoup
elle aussi elle était extrêmement
touchée quand vous faites avec vos
jambes vos pauses pour personne les
personnes de votre entourage quotidien
est ce que vous arrivez à passer à autre
chose est ce que vous arrivez à oublier
ou est-ce que vous en parlez toujours
avec eux je sais que je suis un poids
pour eux avaient d'ailleurs honnêtement
je profitais de ce moment là pour pour
les remercier d'être avec moi et je
pense qu'ils vont tous se reconnaître
parce que ça m'aide vraiment beaucoup et
et je sais que je suis un poids mais
pourquoi un poids parce que je je
je vais je veux au studio que j'appelle
ma thérapie aujourd'hui quand je
travaille avec mes artistes ça me fait
du bien je pense à autre chose mais mais
je ne suis pas réellement efficace dans
le travail je le sais depuis depuis ce
jour là ça a changé
ah oui je sais je suis pas efficace j'ai
une associée en un petit qui est
derrière moi et qui qui gère tout j'ai
des amis qui passent aussi derrière moi
et qui gère tout je suis je suis je suis
absolument pas efficace je le sais ils
me font croire que je me suis joue sans
michel et et ça fait trois mois que vous
a pas vu je vous sens dans le même état
c'est ça qui est qui font que il m'est
plus mal jours après c'est ça qui est
incroyable ça veut dire j'ai
l'impression vous n'arrivez pas à passer
outre cette affaire et a passé autre
chose je me sens comme traître est
atteint je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez y si autour du plateau et gilles
très haut sans une émotion et puis on a
quand même l'impression que vous revivez
cette agression en permanence
moi je voulais vous vous posez une
question parce qu'à l'époque le
président de la république avait dit ces
images font honte à la france c'était
des mots forts tout à l'heure vous avez
dit que vous étiez un peu seul dans la
reconstruction est ce qu'il ya eu un
soutien de la présidence de l'elysée de
l'état est ce qu'on vous aide nous ça va
se faire vous avez eu des news oui
monsieur le président vous a appelé
alors je crois qu'on s'est loupé on a
fait je sais qu on s'est loupé j'étais
aux umj quand encore il m'a
je crois que le président essayait de
vous appeler je vous le dis parce que je
me dis voilà le président m'avait
demandé les coordonnées de michel parce
qu'il voulait contactez michel il vous
appelle vous étiez aux urgences
exactement et donc vous avez eu des
nouvelles de lui depuis
après j'ai eu j'ai eu de nouvelles dans
ce cas ces équipes on demande à nos
équipes de deux de leurs de vous de lui
donner votre numéro
il faut vous aider dans cette affaire
enfin il veut en tout cas que la lumière
soit faite sur cette affaire
oui mais c'est les échos vous avez jeté
des échos que j'ai eus jean michel et
moi j'étais pas là quand un camp comme
michel est élu il ya trois mois
j'en suis désolé si vous mettez un peu
de son panier 1 il avait des matchs de
foot à regarder certains moments où on
se voyait beaucoup avec michel parce que
à un moment j'avais beaucoup se
sentaient beaucoup je faisais prestation
en boîte de nuit et je travaille et que
michel allard mon témoignage n'a aucune
valeur légale
mais si je peux témoigner c'est
quelqu'un qui est doux comme un agneau
il aimera peut-être pas mais c'est un
vrai nounours c'est quelqu'un qui
inspire aucune violence du tout aux
contrats qui est donc je si ça me fait
vraiment de la peine de voir dans cet
état là parce que je sais que c'est
jamais lui qui aurait provoqué ne
serait-ce qu n'importe quelle bagarre
accepta au contraire ils nous servent et
un peu de gardes du corps mais j'ai
souvent le jeu chariot disant t'as pas
quelqu'un d'autre comme garde du coeur
c'est le kit comment tu vas nous
défendre c'est quelqu'un qui est très
doux très sympathique et toujours dans
dans l'empathie excellent ça me fait
vraiment de la peine de le voir encore
mission de ça aujourd'hui effectivement
je voulais qu tueuse
autrefois les pas de lire michel en tout
cas je vous sens satisfait de 2,2
dévoila de de la réponse des pouvoirs
publics
en tout cas je vous sens qui s'est passé
je sens que voulait pas tout nous dire
mais qu' a priori il vous aide là dessus
moi je suis quelqu'un de positif
d'accord dans toutes les situations
j'essaie d'être positif c'est comme ça
que j'avance et
[Musique]
est ce que je ce que je vois aujourd'hui
bon après c'est sûr que je vais pas me
plaindre de la lenteur je pense que
c'est tout et pour tout le monde c'est
pareil j'aimerais que ça aille plus vite
mais j'ai régulièrement des nouvelles de
par mes avocats de l'avancée de donc je
vois que quand même bien il ya quelque
chose choix que ça bouge toutes les
semaines donc j'espère juste que on
pourra passer les étapes et puis et puis
et puis arrivé au procès et puis et puis
que juge si vous pouviez passer à autre
chose ça me j'aimerais bien moi j'ai
produit aujourd'hui michel est-ce que je
quand vous avez dit il ya un instant
vous étiez un poids pour vous associer
pour les gens qui vous côtoient
aujourd'hui vous avez envie de quoi vous
avez envie d'être d'aller mieux
maintenant votre tête c'est le truc qui
vous importe le plus ouais heureusement
je fais un métier qui arrive parce que
quand vous voyez vous quand vous faites
tous ces projets là ça vous fait du bien
bien sûr c'est ma thérapie voilà
honnêtement c'est quand je fais ça oh
moi je je je pense à ça je fais des
artistes qui sont qu'ils sont jeunes qui
qui qui me font qu'ils me font délirer
qui m'emmène avec eux dans leur dans
leurs gilets et là à ce moment là
j'arrive à oublier puis et puis après
voilà je voulais te remercie parce que
c'est vraiment j'ai vu
tu m'as dit que quand j'aurai mes
projets que tu serais pas pour moi et tu
as tenu parole et je sais que nous on
aime ça et je le dis et j'ai vraiment
mal tsb c'est un jeune rappeur qui sort
son premier projet vendredi avec
notamment le clip jules sommes et c'est
vrai que avec le clip le clip est très
très fort je vous invite à aller le voir
dès vendredi
et aussi j'ai un coup de coeur pour
sienna sera d'ailleurs elle sera en live
chez benjamin vendredi où il dit à ne
pas manquer et reviendra peut-être nous
voir car à prendre ou à laisser quand on
prendra pour faire un autre petit live
avec nous parce que je suis j'ai jacques
rocher dont michel moi je te souhaite en
tout cas beaucoup de bonheur un jour
viendra nous voir quand tu veux pour
nous dire comment la faire avance et tu
sais que voilà on est là et j'espère que
la sphère va avancer assez vite et en
tout cas ton message qu'a fait passer
sur la police il était extrêmement
important et une encore fait passer ce
soir
bravo à toi en tout cas voilà pour tt
parole parce que c'est extrêmement
important pour tous les gens qui nous
regardent et parce qu'il ya voilà je
vous dis à beaucoup de familles de
policiers qui m'ont gardé ici et qui se
disent bah moi mon papa ou mon mari et
ben c'est pas un pourri et je suis fier
du métier qui fait voilà merci en tout
cas michel d'avoir été là et tu sais que
le plateau sera toujours ouverte pour
toi et pour tes artistes
merci mon michel